[Music]
this is a completely not lean on
technical talk just get that right out
there no usually literally they take a
break from the technical and I will need
to talk about my company not on the high
street and will be promoting its road
because it are hiring please spread the
word and try to talk about why my
company is like the milky way this is my
background I am an astrophysicist
I converted to a data science about a
year ago I would you see a bank of
computers huge telescopes traveling
around the world also outreach which
will come in later as well as a kind of
a key factor and then I moved to data
science so through the course the
physical course science data science and
moved to take science and now this is my
life I get one computer haven't quite
moved to like Zeus Park and things are
still doing it basic and I look at the
website I try and figure out how things
fit on the website all these sort of
stuff and my favorite item ever on our
website yes that is a plastic pigeon
with a lump in each bump no idea not a
clue it's brilliant no point to
whatsoever well my job is often trying
to relate things like this to a 10,000
pound necklace there is no correlation
my job is to figure out what that
correlation could be and how we can
convince somebody who would like a
10,000 pound necklace that this is
brilliant or what person would actually
like this so my talk is on SMEs no this
is what I know of Annisa me follow my
suggestion when people started talking
to me about SMEs unload so two
catastrophic event that could wipe out
all life on the planet that's the
business model so now initially is a
natural type of company and these
companies are small to medium sized
enterprises and they're usually
independent depends on the country but
they usually have under 250 employees as
a very good reason I want to talk about
these
no one ever does so when I was moving to
beta science we were asked what sort of
company do you want to work for a
start-up or a big established company
both no legit options I have friends who
work in large established companies
where they're going into a data science
team where all of this is set up for
them already I have all those who are
little tiny companies of 12 people but
what about everything else in the middle
and there is a big range of those this
amis are growing their 5.5 million in
the middle of the beginning of 2016 and
these have grown by 2 million since 2000
these companies increasing the
opportunity to work in them are
increasing and the opportunity to work
in them are also so incredibly varied
but good and the employments increasing
these make up at least 99% of every main
industry sector and yet when people move
from data from academia or any other job
to data science these tend to be ignored
so I wanted to explain you what are the
good things and bad things about these
sort of companies and they also put a
lot into the economy the odds of
actually going into one of these
companies are high and they produce 66
percent of all private sector employment
so the real point of this SoCs
disclaimer these are my opinions I would
love any I would love any discussion
please ask questions to now later I'll
put me I'll address up or even while I'm
talking if you have any opinions you
think might be valid briefings missions
but I will keep talking
there's also generalizations in here
when I say big data science be companies
they don't necessarily have a data
science section you might be actually
going into a big company of kind of like
a startup in terms of data science but
I'm going to generalize the above my
company is
a is a medium-sized company we've been
around for 11 years now we are a market
place so we have our own little quirks
we have about 5000 partners these
partners all sell on our website
each of these partners has a different
opinion of what they should be doing so
we're dealing with our partners as
stakeholders we also have everybody else
in the company
we're self-contained company so we have
marketing we have commercial we have PEC
so you also have to do with all these
other individual people who all want the
same thing but don't necessarily want to
do it in the same way so what did I take
from academia and take in to data
science and we'll specifically into my
company great lesson from academia
you're used to working with lots of
different people
I had collaborations all the way around
the world and a little most disclaimer
says often these people will have the
road thoughts as to where your work
should go exactly the same way my
company at this point they'll all have
maybe the same sort of question have
completely different ideas as to where
it should go
marketing want one thing commercial want
another in data we're trying to say you
do know none of those are actually
viable in the timescales you're giving
us so it's like collaboration also the
compromise but not compromising your
integrity and your data in small
companies you might not actually have
this as an option you in a company of
say 1012 people within that company you
might not have that conflict and my
friends in larger company say they don't
particularly in junior level obviously
this changes as you go out get to more
senior levels but in junior levels you
don't have that real conflict you're
collaborating with lots of people but
they don't necessarily have different
ideas for you you're all working on the
same project in the same direction I
found in academia my collaborators
didn't always want my research to go in
that direction they wanted you to go in
their own direction because that helped
this so it's that compromise between
figuring out what you can do and how to
make everybody else happy
perfect example from academia and I use
it every day in my company
and I have a good lesson if you've been
in academia you probably encourage new
outreach probably unwillingly and you
did it because you thought you had to
but this is an incredible skill doing
outreach I actually spent Thursday
evening teaching people in my company
from customer services and commercial
how to do sequel slightly painful but I
fed them cocktails at the same time it's
great fun and those skills you learn
from outreach being able to talk to
anybody about any subject you're
teaching five-year-olds astronomy you
don't start with convex lenses and
galaxy redshift you start with oh look
look where this light has come from and
it is exactly the same talking to
stakeholders
I found start basics assume they know
nothing of what you're talking about
get the level first and then move on the
same as you do in outreach in a start-up
again there's probably a small number of
you you're probably on the same level
you don't have as many stakeholders to
deal with different if you're in
consulting you will have that level
again when you're doing consulting in a
large company my friend she talks to her
boss her boss knows exactly what she's
doing she doesn't have to deal with
stakeholders that's what her boss does
in my company I'm the one getting the
email from my stakeholders saying where
is it what's going on can you please
explain what's happening can you please
explain why you need to do all this
engineering to do it yeah what is an
algorithm one of my favorites and you
get those and you think you don't even
love them but you politely say do you
really want to know here's the math take
them s away and explain and so they
appreciate what you're doing but you
have to do this you have to talk to your
cycles you have to manage your
expectations because if they don't know
what's going on they're not going to use
your data and they're not going to use
your data in the way that you hope that
use your data which is also a very key
point in my research I was in the
driving seat I led my research led it
through and that was it and that's great
because you then know how to basically
this they called yourself in some ways
in small companies everybody knows we're
doing you have your your area you go
through it there's no real conflict as
to whether you're the driver or not
large companies my friend isn't the
drive she told what to do go do I find I
have to be the driver but I also have to
fight to be your driver sometimes I'll
be told we need to do this project but I
won't necessarily been told all the
details of this project I will be told
that this person is very interested they
want to be the driver as well but I know
the data so working with them they kick
co-pilot to the side for a bit and if it
comes to it they can do this in academia
I have to fight for some of my research
because other people for all that is a
nice project I want to do that
please can I take over and you have to
be careful I found this skill very
useful in academia if you don't go into
work you might notice people not my not
your kind of expected to deal with your
own time management I've also found the
same if I don't deal with my time
management properly and a job doesn't
get done it's not bad in academia
someone says fine my job yeah some go so
well so there's a good lesson
those are things I've brought in from
academia and thought I'm really glad I
actually learned that also picked up
some bad habits deadlines are real they
really are and they're urgent
usually closer than you think often I
wanted it yesterday
great thank you would you appreciate
that thought in academia depends on who
you are those plans are usually is a
grants in two months time most academics
will start the work a week beforehand so
you used to tight deadlines
I've been up so many nights because my
supervisors hit oh there's a grant
deadline can you do all this work like
two months of work it's in five days the
deadlines are real you have to stick to
them otherwise people who face in what
you're doing and to the fair this is
actually across all data science I know
in big companies my friends who I've
been talking to about this he doesn't
necessarily have that urgency of
deadlines have buffs deals with vats if
she misses a deadline
it's on his head obviously that's not a
good thing to do but I'm the one they
come to if it goes by the date if the
data they've got doesn't appear where
they said it would appear at that point
and potentially in small companies you
have a bit more flexibility with those
deadlines they're not as urgent they're
not coming from a different area now
that may or may not be true but this is
definitely one of the things I found
most hard deadlines are there they're
set you know you have to give the board
their data by this point or that board
meetings not happening and you've just
wasted 20 people time you don't have
control over your data in a certainly
astrophysics very very secretive about
their data it might when they publish it
go in the paper and you have access to
it
I found reproducibility was not a real
thing in astrophysics it kind of might
be able to do it but they want to keep
their secrets in my company but you
don't get to keep your data in your
secrets in fact you're asked to share
more to the point you have to sometimes
force it down people's throats
please use data you have all these
numbers that your company is saying
where does it come from can somebody
please tell me where this number of 40%
of the people and their site do this
comes from usually if it's somebody
who's imagined it so we have to get them
using the data so not only do not have
sole control over your data you have to
make people use it you have a flipside
you don't necessarily have full control
over the data in your company but you
are responsible for that data if you
lose your astrophysics data someone will
frown not not be happy maybe you get
scooped if I lose the personal
identifiable information from my company
oh I get fired and they get sued for
millions so it's this weird situation
where you don't actually have control
over your data but you have to protect
it as much as possible from outside the
company it's a difficult place to be
it's delicate
but it's definitely an interesting place
to be as reading with purse people
personal credit information is
terrifying I don't want it I have to be
able to use it but I don't want it so
and to refer this one again is probably
throughout all data if you leave that
laptop on the train like the government
of them it will hit the news no mask bad
message you're going to have to switch
between projects I had one project in
academia I worked on that day in day out
that was my work you work on it so you
have a paper you then probably do
another paper based on that work I work
on multiple things at the same time I
will work on stuff that somebody else
has done and move it forward and then
they take it over you don't have the
luxury of working on one project I know
people in small and large companies do
have that luxury that is what that
starts would be doing right now you're
working on that in a big company my
friend is told this is her project she's
on that for the next six months I'm
working on recommender systems I'm
working on how to actually score rare
products 10,000 pound necklace plastic
pigeon how exactly does one rate those
somebody who wants a plastic pigeon
doesn't necessarily want a 10,000 pound
necklace how do we show them that so
they don't have to hump through 100,000
products who are our partners what are
they doing all of these things I can
work on for an hour a day and they all
have to be done a car prioritize one or
the other because I'm told they all have
to be done and there's only two of us in
the data science team so if the other
data scientist goes a holiday yeah I
need to pick up his work if I tell you
anything
comment please comment code if you will
save your life or it'll certainly save
mine if I'm working with you because you
have to pick up projects that other
people have been working on you don't
have the luxury of having that sold
product and it can be frustrating in
academia you have that paper your name
is on that paper you presented a
conference and everybody knows that is
your work
somebody picks up my work and finishing
it they present it it's their work they
finished it even if I started it but
equally if I pick up the work and I
finish it then I present it so it's
difficult you have to work more as a
team where I found in academia you often
you're looking out for you you want your
name on that paper so I probably zip
through that a lot quicker than I
thought but I really would like
discussion as to what people think if
you're not willing to tell me nice my
email address is there also if you are
interested in the career at night on the
high street many very challenges a great
place to work come and speak to me or
send a contact to the careers at Norton
High Street thank you very much or
comments why did you leave a kadhi Tommy
with the low stuff I didn't want to work
weekends anymore I didn't want to work
evenings anymore
and I wanted to settle down in one
country so I've been moving all across
the world you settle somewhere you get
settled you buy a sofa you sell the sofa
you movie two boxes so for me it was
more of a lifestyle choice and I found
its work I don't work she says what can
weekend I don't work weekends I don't
work evenings I get to go home on a
night doesn't say I won't necessarily do
that if I get in fighting on a project
but I don't have to and I get to choose
the city that I live in and still do the
really fun cool stuff like she learning
and such
the more of an observation you talk
about SME gettin sir
one of the most destiny basically fell
ecstatic inside there's a small number
of SMEs it's a very important to the
economy
they're very fast-growing couple
tensions of our own yeah and possibly
more interesting to work yes definitely
so no it depends on the company for
example mine is looking at expanding so
within the next year they will break
that SME barrier and move forward they
also want to go international those are
the companies that can as you said can
be very exciting because the
opportunities can expand rapidly yeah
but it can be a static field depends on
the company and my academic not really
but that's when you my experience so I
had to manage my my outreach work and
like one project and that was a big
project we I guess you had multiple
elements to it but the main thing was
one large project whereas here I can be
managing like six different projects all
on the go at the same time with the same
deadline and they will have to be done
at that same point and within academia I
was often dealing with the same people
for that same different processing
project whereas here I'm dealing with
multiple people from different fields so
each one feels very isolated and very
different yeah
you're thinking would be easy wouldn't
it and it can be my company is in some
ways a very soft company it's not a full
tech company we have people with
marketing we have people who just take
photos you've never heard of an
algorithm
you know I'm asked what is data science
multiple times and I hate answering a
question because I still don't know how
to sew actually then you say ok I've
grown up a degree in astrophysics more
likely they're going to step back and
say oh do you just know I can't talk to
you you're too smart sometimes no I'm
not I'm fine ok and
because they don't understand I think
maybe if you go to a full tech company
it is that different so mine is more
convincing people that I can talk to you
as a human being I'm not an Android in a
robot despite what you think and you
know what I do is important and here's
how you can use this data and it will
improve their lives so I've been doing a
lot of company outreach to try and
convince people that data is great data
is fun yes I literally fed them
cocktails well teaching them SQL and it
works because it's something softer they
can enjoy but they're still actually
learning without learning so I think
maybe my experience is different because
it was that almost you have to push
harder for anyone to just understand
data not to push harder because I want
them to believe me so I guess I got I
got really lucky my company is great if
anybody does have any comments or such
I've pulled the very small people for
this one yes we were in Richmond
Richmond so kind of south west beautiful
area right on the river yes it's a
gorgeous building with loads of great
people so it's not central London and so
if you do live in the southwest you
literally perfect because you don't have
to go into native London but we do have
a lot of people who commute because you
can get the district lines straight
through to Richmond
if anybody does have any comments I
pulled a very small number of people and
I would like to may seen international
projects we're all on the same
wavelength we want this one product you
know we're all interested in
astrophysics in this one path of
astrophysics I find my stakeholders will
come to me with a question that isn't
necessarily defined properly I find in
astrophysics they knew how to phrase the
question to start with whereas in my
stakeholders because they're coming from
such diverse backgrounds will phrase it
however they need to but that might not
match up with the data so very similar
sort of spoken right in the data kind
they might think it's a great idea in a
great project but feasibly it's not
possible where is in academia they
generally knew the data as well as you
did when working with these said
stakeholders also when you give them the
data back in academia you generally on a
reasonably similar level you know where
you're going yet cetera so you can be
more technical you can go into more
details and you can have more
discussions with them on a technical
basis whereas my stakeholders if I talk
to them in technical terms I've lost
them within ten seconds so I have to
somehow pass that data so that they can
understand it while still getting from
them what they really want and also
convincing them that I'm not going to
give them the data to answer their
question exactly how they want because
that's not necessarily what the data
sees in astrophysics I find that was not
an issue they want to see what the data
says and then draw their conclusions
some of them some of them did want to
change the data I found that's a lot
more prevalent with my stakeholders now
they have an idea as to what the data
should say and it's much more of a motor
communication issue I think you have to
communicate on a different level and
explain data and a lot more more
detailed but less detail is kind of
awkward level
yes definitely more insights a lot of
the problem he's trying to get the in
such from them as well as to actually
you know they want to know okay what is
a loyal customer define loyal somebody
abides with us define how often lots
know and so actually figuring out what
they want that getting that insight from
them and actually giving that insight
back takes a lot more work to try and
forgot where each of your coming from
astrophysics your tend to come from the
same area so I didn't find it as much of
a problem not now
I probably would done at the time
because it's scary changing your
completely changing your life and
everything called career now I love the
the challenges in astrophysics you get
one problem you deal with that problem
for six months a year etc and you
produce that paper here it's much more
fast paced you have different problems
I'm literally trying to figure out how
to define a customer journey
it sounds simple but then you look at
the data and then somebody comes in and
wants something else so it's a lot more
fast-paced I find I'm actually I feel
like I'm giving a lot more back I give
one paper in academia and I work six
months to do so here I'm at board
meetings every week I'm giving back the
data I'm actually feel like I'm
accomplishing a lot more it might be in
smaller amounts but to me yeah I
wouldn't go back I find the excitement
the skills that I'm learning I can pick
up now I spent two weeks and picked up
MPL in academia you don't really get the
chance to do that your focus in one area
if you pick up a new skill it's for that
and it is a long-term thing here you can
pick up drops it's very dynamic and very
exciting it means you know you don't get
bored at all
yes yes so a lot of it is also figuring
out how you actually drove it properly
so it can be really difficult you're
trying to explain to them look okay
that's not possible
yes what is the comfort what is a little
customer give us a definition and you
have to explain to them so you have to
literally almost force them out the car
hijack it a little bit and jump in the
driver's seat and it can be a battle hmm
yes um yeah so to be honest it depends
if it's a CEO asking me or someone to go
surfing
there are times you have to literally
relinquish control if it's a CEO or one
of the execs yes sir I'm on it if it's
someone else then often I'll sit down
with them and say okay why do you think
this where is this coming from
can I get anything out of them and maybe
they have an interesting question in
their head it's just not what they've
asked me because they don't understand
the relationship between the data and
what they're doing so actually had very
similar asking what straight to the lip
line is like why so we want to know
where customers live so actually did a
spatial where a spatial thing looking at
actually where our loyal customers and I
do find you all myself because I
couldn't get an answer and try to show
them look it doesn't really make a
difference where they live there's no
difference but for me I enjoyed that
because I got to learn new skills from
it
so sometimes it is that balance but I
know the question is going to be useless
but well I got some tech I can play with
and you take it to your own advantage
so climbing on this one so management
people asking for something you have to
account the planetoid and they have to
give them some timeframe and you
probably nothing if you haven't - kiliel
be good I take a Scottie method multiply
it by four it's most likely to take
twice as long as you expect and then
when you get it done you seem like a
miracle worker yeah so then yes yeah
those situations usually we talk to the
whole team what we think is the option
we bring in the stakeholders so they can
discuss their problem they can discuss
their problem and there's a group we can
decide okay absolutely your problem is
more important then it's a matter of
okay we've got all of this work we use
and agile environments so we have a
backlog of work we have to experience
and we section at those two weeks we
also make sure we try to make sure that
what goes in those two weeks is what we
do nothing else comes in nothing else
goes out unless it's absolutely urgent
so we section off that time and plan
ahead we try not to deal with unless
it's going to take less than an hour we
don't deal with little things coming in
saying look I need this now if you
needed it now you should have asked us a
while ago we do take into account as
April 5th we said we had an audit all of
a sudden finance is going to get all our
attention because that's what's
necessary so it can be very difficult
usually we try to make sure that not one
person deals with that we bring it in as
a team and then we bring the two sets of
stakeholders are competing we'll bring
them in and they can also talk to each
other so when we choose one or the other
they have an understanding of why we did
that sports involved and we still try
and do their project maybe one person
from our team will give them a little
bit of support and help and try and work
it that way it's a communication and a
compromise I found that I'm much more
involved than some of my friends in
bigger companies in that so I'm learning
those skills of the stakeholder
management a lot more than they would in
a much bigger company where I'm kind of
protected from that
I'm on the front line it's great I don't
always think it's great but it is great
yeah I'm in a company and you're
defending all the persons there's maybe
a holiday they may be running off they
made for busy yeah exercising
frustration isn't it yep yes so that's
always helpful when you've got multiple
things to work on we try in our company
to be pretty strict with so we have we
work in a natural way so we have their
two-week sprints and we actually contact
the people who are going to have
dependencies on beginning adept Springs
and say are you going to be away at any
point so we have an idea as to what
dependencies we have it's not an answer
was actually solved
putting resolved we will still suddenly
realize okay we reliant on this one
person and they're not answering their
emails and they're working from home
it's not going to work in that case it's
usually it's their project we're working
on if we can't get access to them and
that I'm sorry you we're working on your
work
the only real problems we have with
DevOps usually they work in the building
so we can go and say hi can you fix red
shift fourth please yeah in academia I
did also find the same thing if I was
asking from data from somebody the
difference being there in Chicago and
I'm here in my building they're
generally upstairs or working from home
in which case they will be in the office
at some point so I can go in and
literally sit next to their desk and say
hello give you the data please whereas
if I've got to fly to Chicago it's not
going to happen so it is different but
yet the frustrations are not solved best
unsolved
Tech t yeah finish early what you
described as I so the system already
been in place before you do yes so what
you experienced would suggest that we
should be quite care for the company
select and what he'll give a concert
with company because he cannot change it
when we decided yes so company culture
is definitely very important and you
have to fit properly or you're just
going to rub up there on the front way
I've personally really liked the agile
method and I was really glad I used it
in my CVS course and I was really glad
when they continued in my company
actually a complete agile system broke
down before Christmas we lost their
scrum master and everything just
collapse as a whole team we were
completing nothing because everybody was
here there and everywhere so we actually
changed their culture we pull together
as a team and decided ok these are
things that work for us these are things
that don't so I think when picking a
company it's not only what they do but
they're willing to change and adapt and
work things out so for example it's more
company I always just stand ups even if
they don't do it even if it might not be
the stand-ups and ok can we meet for
five minutes each morning and have a
coffee and connect so I'm not pulling it
in so I find the ability to ability to
be open to change is some it was for me
personally a very important point of
culture and sometimes there's no way to
figure it out before you go you go for
an interview you can talk to other
people there you can do things like
graphs cross craft or but obviously
you're getting just negative user so you
have to balance that out exactly
exactly so it's always somewhat biased
and the only way is to go and see them
I've actually been interviewing recently
and one place I went to there four times
because I couldn't connect with it and I
turn the job down because I couldn't
connect with it and it was that come for
the job seemed perfect but there was
something that just wasn't clicking for
me and culture is extremely important
probably more so than the job itself you
can change the job you will not be able
to change the culture but yeah that's
just my experience
thank you very much missing
[Applause]
[Music]